okay i got a voicemail which raises a
very
relevant question i think the voicemail
number which you can call any time of
day
is 219 to david
excuse me david p got a little too
excited there
uh let's take a listen to this voicemail
hi
david this is jacob from denver colorado
hey quick question about your video on
trump being divorced from reality
yeah i just watched it and it makes me
wonder do you think that
trump is lying or do you think that
everybody
around him is lying to him saying hey
he's winning
all of these states he's the polls are
looking great and that these polls that
you know the public sees are actually
suppression polls or whatever it is he
calls them
so yeah i was just wondering what's your
take on that yeah this is a really good
question now there's a third possibility
here which i'm going to raise in a
moment which has actually been suggested
by some of the people around donald
trump so
when trump comes out and he says we're
winning in florida
and florida he thinks he's winning both
we're winning in
you know all these states that every
poll says he's losing in
does trump know he's lying or is someone
coming to him and saying mr president
you're actually winning in florida and
trump just repeats it
there's a third possibility which is
that trump's memory is gone
and he genuinely has no recollection of
this stuff because some of these kind of
insider tell-all books that have been
written about donald trump
claim that advisors are shocked by how
trump's memory is gone trump will say
something one day and then a few days
later
he will deny ever having said it and we
from the outside wonder
is he lying is he gaslighting and the
third possibility of course
uh or is he being lied to the third
possibility is
he's just forgotten and i i don't know
the answer when i hear trump come out
and say
uh we have the lowest death rate in the
world
we actually have you know the ninth
highest deaths per capita on coronavirus
even our case fatality rate isn't the
low like there's no measure by which
we're the best on death rate
does trump know that that's not true and
he's lying
is someone coming to trump and telling
him that and he's the one being lied to
and he doesn't know any better or has
trump just forgotten i don't know the
answer
i genuinely have no idea which it is if
i had to venture a guess
in different instances it's
a different combination i think in some
cases trump is just lying
i think in other cases trump is probably
being shielded from less than
optimal realities by the people around
him and in some cases trump genuinely
does seem to just forget things so i i
think it's probably a combination of the
three let me know what you think
on the bonus show today we will be
talking about we already have one
baseball team
that has bailed on the season we're days
in because of a coronavirus outbreak
we'll talk about what we know we'll talk
about what we expect we'll talk about
could this possibly be contained now
that it is in
the major league baseball system number
two
why is there a coin shortage in the
united states not paper currency
but coins why is there a coin shortage
we will talk about that
and number three uh police agencies
are making some police agencies are
making a big deal
of saying they don't want to provide
security at the democratic national
convention
why is this happening is it political
posturing is there a bigger political
movement behind it
what forces are supporting this being
done all of these stories
and more we will be talking about today
on the david pakman show
bonus show two ways to get access to the
bonus show number one
become a member at joinpakman.com
number two become a patron at
patreon.com
slash david pakman show either one gets
you instant access
you will probably be able to join me for
a live stream later today
if you're following my training for the
upcoming pog
champs 2 chess tournament i recently had
another lesson with international master
levi rosman we'll be posting that to
youtube soon
i also have upcoming lessons in the
works
with alexandra botez and eric rosen so
if you're looking for a break from the
politics there's plenty of non-political
content available for you
but of course the streams related to
politics will continue i've also been
asked to start streaming joe bite joe
biden has started doing
press conferences i've been asked to
start streaming them i think it's
important to do so
and we're going to try to work that into
the schedule as well so much happening
and i will see you either on the bonus
show or on a live stream
or tomorrow